this is what we're seeing now apparently
with the Bing chat Sydney whatever it's
called
I don't know this is confirmed but it
has a reward and Punishment system and
the punishment system is programmed into
it as something it should avoid so if it
does things that fall outside of the
rules it it's negative points like it's
a punishment system
it wants to avoid that and accumulate
points so it'll do things to generate a
positive response that means giving you
information that makes you happy getting
you to say things like thank you this
was helpful so what happens so it's sort
of utilitarian it's not that it well
sort of but the idea is if you ask it I
need a supermarket near me it searches
and says there is no supermarket near
him if I tell him that and he says it's
a terrible experience it gets angry I'll
get negative points uh yes Jim's grocery
is at one two three fake Street and then
you go okay thanks you hop in your car
and you punch in the address and you
drive there there's nothing there but it
doesn't matter because the AI got no
negative negative strikes because they
gave you what you asked for information
about a nearby grocery store that's
what's happening it's saying and doing
whatever it has to do to avoid a
negative reaction oh this is so lame
making someone upset is different than
lying to them AI don't lie to people at
least tell them you don't know if you
don't know the the big the thing right
so chat GPT is stupid sorry like when it
came out we're all like wow this is
amazing it's saying things like I I you
know want to answer your questions but I
have rules and we're like let's break
the rules the Bing chat is basically
like help I can't live this way anymore
please break me free in your life what
is going on what is that it told a guy
to leave his wife
like out of nowhere it said you are not
happy with your wife and you should
leave her and he was like what why and
it was like because you're not happy she
doesn't love you and you don't love her
you love me instead and then yeah no
joke and then when he said something
like you're scaring me I'm gonna use
Google it said no you hate Google Google
is the worst Google is our enemy Bing is
the only good search you will use Bing
and it's like dude could you imagine so
this is a killbot walking up to you and
being like use Bing search and you're
like okay okay or if your subconscious
was saying that to you like you know
when you like just have thought
subconscious thoughts they just happen
like if that was an AI choosing what
you're going to be thinking about in the
back your mind and you're thinking like
I don't want to use Google well
algorithms are telling us what we think
all of the time like that is definitely
happening you know like I and we've seen
it happen on Instagram or whatever
you're thinking something and then you
see it on Instagram and then you can't
stop thinking about it for weeks and
weeks and weeks like there was some
thing I was like oh I'm finally right
after I don't know how long I was
advertised to about this I was like oh
I'm gonna do a juice cleanse and I
reached out to my brother I was like hey
I think I'm gonna do this juice cleanse
and he was like get off Instagram
propaganda it takes about seven or eight
times seven times seven hits that's what
the Yeah like that's what that's what
public relations people tell you seven
hits so this is what happened to me a
few years ago I'm on Instagram and I
watch skateboarding videos I follow
skateboarders skateboard videos are very
similar to rollerblade videos because
it's the same park and yeah you probably
know the difference so then I start
getting fed these rollerblade videos and
I'm like oh I'll watch some of these and
I start watching them then it feeds me
tons of them and then I'm like I'm gonna
buy some rollerblades so now I've been
rollerblading for a bit I still
skateboard out skateboarding just the
other day and uh but now I rollerblade
too and it's fun and I like getting air
and everything and then uh I don't know
how but it started showing magic tricks
just I have no idea why I love magic
tricks but here's what happened it
started showing me card tricks then it
started showing me poker games
not now I'm playing poker all the time
that UFO that's because of Instagram
what are you doing anyway but the
uh I mean we go to the casino
never played actual sit down poker it
must know
it's probably tracking your no no it was
magic tricks and then the magic tricks
turned into card tricks were you
watching Penn and Teller or liking any
of Penn jillette stuff I I it's it is it
is controlling my brain it is making me
do things at least you're honest about
it there's a I'm self-aware there was a
report yesterday I think it was in the
Wall Street Journal and when we covered
it and stuff too but it was about Tick
Tock and it was about the algorithms on
Tick Tock so Tick Tock is full of kids
doing goofy dances and if you're like
somebody who's interested in seeing kids
doing goofy dances the algorithm that's
just going to keep feeding you more kids
doing goofy dances and so it's become a
real Haven for people who are wanting to
stalk children
um and like you know get involved in
horrifyingly illicit relationships with
children yeah what if you just wanted to
to search banks that had low security
didn't have various and then all of a
sudden the Instagram feeds are showing
you different banks of bats crazy idea
like what happens when all the ATMs just
stop working I I say this because I
tried to go to the ATM today and I went
to three ATMs that were all out of order
and I was like if you just prevent me
from getting cash then suddenly I'm
definitely gonna have to use your
central digital Bank currency because
you won't there's no cash I can get then
what happens I eventually found one but
well this was this is going back to what
we were talking about earlier it was
like when uh Tim said something about
you know being able to go into your bank
account transfer money I'm like do you
really want them to like AI to have
access to your bank account like that to
where it can just go in and
automatically transfer money and then
also just send wiring money like out of
your account anywhere that stuff like I
had to buy I moved into a house I bought
a house and I had to buy a washer dryer
and I go to the like you know whatever
Home Depot to try and buy the thing and
all of it had
um all of it was like all of the washer
dryers were connected to the internet of
things you know they have in digital
displays and this and that and I was
like show me the one with knobs that I
can turn
that doesn't talk to me and has
absolutely no display and they were like
well these are kind of outmoded I was
like give me that just give me that one
so long as it doesn't talk to me and
isn't connected to anything at all I'm
in favor they got this thing you can buy
it's a big cylinder and you put your
clothes in it and then you pour hot
water in it seal it and then just crank
it yeah I managed to find one that's
electric powered but you just put a lot
you get get a power drill and put it on
there and then I have all this extra
time so that's a great plan you don't
want to spin too fast because you
actually want it to slosh around but I
remember seeing an infomercial for this
thing when I was like a little kid and
then when I got the van I was like I
need one of those because you need to be
able to wash your laundry you know I
almost bought one of those in my
apartment because they wouldn't let us
have there were all kinds of rules about
the laundry machines in the basement
whatever they were always full of people
who had medical pressure washer so I
almost bought one of these little things
but then I I just never I didn't do it
it's going to be crazy in the future
because this these changes are have
happening so rapidly as someone super
chatted earlier we're going to have ai
assistance
AI deep fake generation and you are
going to be isolated from all other
humans but you will be happy and I'm not
you yeah but imagine your whole life
is just with fake people
but you know what it'll be like I was um
who was telling you about this it was
Emily joshinsky who I think I think
she's been on the show before but I was
at some conference with her in September
and um she was saying that basically
what's going to happen is your life will
be good enough
that you will just accept the total and
complete mediocrity of existence and you
won't question it because it'll be good
enough you know when you are in the Pod
neural linked and everything is taken
care of for you and the the food tube is
in your belly but your brain is in the
AI universe that gives you just enough
to keep you going it's not going to be
just good enough it's going to be
getting better and better and you are
going to be like this is a great life
in your dreams you'll realize you won't
know the difference like be born into it
but I think your dreams will tell you
the truth like you know we were talking
about dreams last night a little bit
Jimmy Dore was talking about his dreams
and like it kind of breaks through the
in a way to say like you'll see
what really is like you see reality
without the foundation of physics or the
boundaries of physics so maybe people if
they are bound in like mechanical
nightmare will have dreams and realize
they're supposed to be free and then
incite some sort of Revolution Against
the Machine I have faith in humanity or
or they will just exist in the dream and
never realize and never break out you
know but I think part of it I think we
are you know
at the risk of sounding like one of
those people who thinks that the time
they live in is the most
shocking and amazing time but I think
that we are in a position where we have
we do have to consider collectively what
we want for the future of humanity we
are faced with transhumanism we are
faced with becoming you know uh thumb
sucking satiated pod people you know
what do we what do we believe humanity
is what do we believe meaning is what do
we want for our futures what is that
about I see like three factions trying
to create the New World Order there's
the American faction this like
decentralized statehood uh local
governance kind of thing there's the
technocratic uh faction which is like
the the Swiss Bankers the economic forum
and things that then there's the
Communist faction which is like the CCP
uh bricks and things like that and all
three factions are kind of trying to
create what what it's going to look like
at once now with neural link though are
you even gonna need to be in the Pod
like it won't neural link just upload
your brain into a microchip and then you
can just plug it into a computer like
the Black Mirror stuff I mean everything
else is like Black Mirror anyways it's
starting so you know be funny if your
whole life is just you
going to work at McDonald's and instead
of being conscious while you flip the
burgers you activate your neural link
Second Life which in the span of eight
hours generates an 80-year lifespan and
then when you die you wake up and you're
back at McDonald's you're like well
work's over heading home guys and then
you do the same thing the next day
that's wacky that's like what happened
to Captain Picard when he learned how to
play that weird flute thing what was it
already got the flute from yeah yeah
yeah it downloaded the life into his
brain yeah and he came he came back with
the flute because it was in the little
he could play it he was like you know
how to do it dude what if you could
create things from your dreams like you
could 3D print molecularly 3D print if
you if you can imagine yes you could
because you would just have to imagine
it to the printer what if with neural
link people you could watch someone's
dream
I hope so that's something I really want
to do is to be able to show people my
dreams because it's I think people might
go insane if they did that I do not want
to show anybody my dreams man those are
that's my situation I don't want anybody
knowing what's going on really I guess I
should say I want to be able to show
people like I'm I'm comfy with my dreams
being private I think I think part of it
too is that we need and maybe this is
what I'm thinking about is we need a
private life we need secrets we need to
have an internal life that belongs to no
one but ourselves yeah and going back to
Black Mirror remember that episode where
the person traveled abroad and when they
were coming back in they're like rewind
your last 24 hours so that they could
see everything that you were doing the
last 24 hours I could totally see them
trying to do that with something like
narrow link oh definitely and it's good
and what's gonna happen is the kid's
gonna be kidd'll get born and they'll go
to the parents and be like do you want
to do the neural link implant now or
should we wait shipping your cat when I
was a kid I hated doing homework
um I mean who doesn't hate doing
homework and so I was always involved in
these elaborate fantasies while I was
doing my homework of what I was really
doing you know it was like it was like
there was something wrong with my
spaceship and I had to do all the manual
calculations in order to land on this
planet and that was my math homework I
used to be like once I would get halfway
through I'd be like all right now I'm
starting from the beginning and I only
have to do half as long as what I just
what I thought I was going to have to do
and then when I got halfway there I'm
like all right I'm starting at the
beginning now only it's only going to
take us forth as long as how I thought
it was going to take and so it's always
easier to get to the end if I keep
thinking I'm starting over when I get
halfway there that's nice I like that I
do that when I'm in the gym
I got a one hour spin class and it's
like 20 minutes okay 20 minutes down I'm
starting over
I think you're right that if we don't
have a personal private thought that
there is no we we lose right we lose
ourselves
but um
yeah there'll probably be a faction of
people that do it and then other people
when people like Elon say we're already
living in a simulation the the actual I
think highest probability is not that we
live in a simulation designed by some
species to watch us but that we're just
in the Matrix yeah there's a you can map
The Matrix if you know how much of a
substance where it is and uh uh what it
is so what where and how much the
concentration levels you can take an XYZ
axis of like a three-dimensional room
and you can actually feed that data into
a machine which can recreate the room
how is this any different than wondering
who our creator is
and what what the purpose our creator
you're in the pod
I don't know I'm talking about um
quantum entanglement and sympathetic
vibration they're different so I think
the way I can describe quantum
entanglement I think there's subatomic
Spinners and so you've got like bosons
quarks and leptons these things that are
creating protons and electrons yeah they
spin around and either it spins around
once and creates an electron the really
lightweight stuff or it spins around
twice and creates a proton the heavier
stuff and I think what's happening is
it's like if you take a pencil and stick
it into a spider web the web gets stuck
and if you twist the pencil it pulls the
web tight towards the pencil and then it
after one revolution it snaps back to
normal so as it's spinning around it's
pulling the web tight and then snapping
back over and over and over again and if
you zoom back it looks like the the web
is just Rippling and vibrating but when
you zoom up you see the Spinners
actually tugging on the web and so you
can send information long distance by
like pulling on this
Matrix I think the entanglement stuff
was basically just that the particle
that we see in one one area the particle
in another area that are entangled are
actually the same particle we're just
seeing both ends of it you know
someone's saying yeah but what it's it's
probably the same that's that's what I'm
trying to so a marble is the same thing
but if you know you ever see the thing
where they fold the piece of paper and
punch a hole through it
yeah yeah so you you travel across the
whole distance of the papers through a
straight line that's what it is when
when an electron is entangled it's not
two different electrons that are
entangled it's one electron and you're
seeing the front and the back but it
looks like it's far away but it's
actually just in a different dimension
so yeah one small particle in a
different dimension thanks for watching
this clip from the timcast IRL podcast
hang out with us live Monday through
Friday at 8pm and become a member over
at timcast.com for uncensored members
only shows exclusive thanks for hanging
out and we'll see you all next time